producer actor writer comedian Lions fan
Penn State fan keegan-michael key
joining us he's got a new show on
Netflix friends from college also be
seeing it you can see him in Horatio
he's Horatio and Hamlet off Broadway
that'd be great if people give me an
image I'd love to do a play called
Horatio yeah I'm gonna have to ask
ratios perform about permission to allow
you to me exactly so your Horatio and
Hamlet off-broadway at the Public
Theater do you have to work on your
dialect your accent it's actually very
interesting with this particular show I
was because my training but my mother
Shakespearean trained actor and so we I
got to rehearsal and I started
immediately doing what we call admitted
Atlantic dialect which is to say
something like you know like try to
think of how how it would happen you
know every word you would say would
sound more English that's what or like
Kate Hepburn Kate Hepburn was not doing
an English accent she was doing a
mid-atlantic accent so you you're
speaking as if you sound like you live
in the middle of the Atlantic Ocean so
you're not English but you're also not
American
so you're sand and I was doing that the
directors like stop stop Keegan I'm one
thing from you I need one thing I want
this to be like the most cutest Horatio
possible
I want your Midwestern detroit dialect I
don't want any I want it to feel as
accessible as possible let me hear the
troit wellthat Detroit it's just as
opposed to like my cousins who live in
Detroit who would be like you know to be
that is the question whether tis nobler
in the mind to suffer the slings and
arrows of outrageous fortune or you know
this so it's as opposed to an urban
dialect like that now so every time he
goes yeah you kind of soften up those
R's and the vowels are too
understandable I want you to really just
Keegan eyes it for me well can't we
bring Detroit into Hamlet the way we
brought rap into Hamilton it's exactly
and very often because what I'll happen
you'll see african-americans will all
try to do that mid-atlantic thing and
I'm it's so funny that I'm trying it's
funny when I'm on stage I can do the
speeches that pause that you heard
earlier it was me going how come you
know so the difference between two
nights together had these gentlemen
Marcellus and Bernardo on their watch in
the dead waste and middle of the night
been thus encountered a figure like
you're
father appears before them with
intermediate it's like it if you know
appears before them and with solar March
goes slow and stately by them for ice he
walks like an etruscan fear surprise
denies once paid this but you know it's
like it's like it's all okay great it
sounds British I don't know what the
hell's going on what is your best accent
what's my best accent I think I mean
probably like impersonating my cousins
from the South is probably my favorite
one to do when you when you're just
talking like you know a male listen hey
let me ask you a question me a hobby
playing I become live in Salt Lake City
he Messiah he say a lay a me a cheese
cause because cuz he just call me
because cuz the ladies man I can't get
the ladies off of me man I'll try not to
get some stuff up in here yeah but then
also I grew up it so close to Canada in
Canada but we didn't we were poor we
didn't have we don't have cable so
windsors writer Granger is right across
the way so all half of the Canadian
Broadcasting you see is British shows so
I grew up doing like you know holidays
you know like you know love gum
variations cockney by Alexis doubler net
for my from my mom from the stepmom my
dad second one is from a okay but then
you have the wire where you have a lot
of British actors who came over we were
so Salem or I'm so Dan we wish so
smashing along the black actor the black
American actor was safe for so long and
then just frickin a dress and TfL and
Eamonn and Lenny we got your eyes on you
guys it's a it's the worst we wrote a
key and peele sketch about it just like
well what's up over said white actors
screwed yeah we're good it's got the
corner market we got to market it so
that we got the quick we got the week
we're good to go here while you weren't
what you didn't keep your eye on their
killer and well because when I first
sort of watching the wire I have no idea
how those die for it happened half the
Royal Shakespeare Company's not on the
wire and doing like really good
Baltimore accent yes yeah how is that
though it's it easier to do the American
accent or British on yes because in our
production of Hamlet we have two actors
right now that are both British and they
tell us all the time remember you have
to remember 70% of our culture growing
up his children was watching American
television you guys don't watch i watch
british television but i grew up in a
place regionally in america where that
can
but you don't and I was raised by a
European my stepmothers you know is from
Ireland so I'm exposed to that culture
if you live in Dayton if you live in
truth and Consequences New Mexico if you
live in Spokane you're just watching
American TV but so are the Australians
in the English so every young British
actress they all have this like valley
girl American accent they can do because
that's all that they see on TV
I mean therapy there are people from
England have watched more episodes of
friends than I have it's early it's like
me and you do love friend I love me I
also love friends from college on
Netflix what do people say to you on the
street you live in New York part time if
you walk down a block here in the
village to this day you still hears what
how in the village you get this and the
village you get love your work and then
they keep on going it's drive-bys it's
all drive-bys in the village you get
into Midtown and Iran it's all sub it's
all the substitute teachers schedule can
feel and I can't like I can't be on in
Times Square without like a hat partial
plastic surgery glasses I need to take a
vertebra out so I could just completely
transform but those are tourists okay
that's the problem low down the locals
especially downtown it's just like a or
construction workers are the best like
there's the funny guy funny guy
well he does keep I used to get a Sports
Center dude SportsCenter yeah or and I
end every day just to keep me humble I
get at least a good dozen feel amazed
appeal is that people have been going
down into the subway they do they do you
respond to it and no I'm that penny I do
not know how Jordan one time was sitting
on the Upper West Side but there was sit
in a bus stop I don't know why we sit in
a bus stop but is there that bus stop
just lost in his phone and those guys
drove up in the car with their windows
down and they got to a red light that's
just about to turn green those guys that
the passengers he goes okay then Jordan
kind of looks up in the car who turned
electrons green hard drives away it's
about 50 yards up check this fire going
to open her shadow pick up a key check
the Gouda like with him Oh kill the guy
was crestfallen there's a sketch when
you guys are talking about movies yes
parking
yes when was the village that was
thought of my favor and then we did one
with Liam Neeson he was we did one with
Liam Neeson he was great to hear an
Irishman do that it's fantastic
what's the one skit where you went
there's there we can't do this we did
you have to get approval of some of them
there were sketches that we wanted to do
that we didn't do that we got approval
for we got approval for a 911 sketch
from Comedy Central and we decided we
thought it was inappropriate where it
was we and we were talking about it we
read it we went over it no it was just
this one sketch they it was carte
blanche over there that you know how
edgy that network can be him there was
one sketch that Jordan had done with one
of our writers they had a two-person
show years and years and years ago and
it's really quite good it was all of the
footage that was on the floor from any
9/11 documentary ever been made like and
they were watching him an 11 documentary
one day on the anniversary and they went
what footage would be in an interview
that would not make it into a 911
documentary like is there other people
who are so sociopathic that they
wouldn't know how to be appropriate and
they wrote that sketch so online kids
there they wrote that session we made a
documentary of all the stuff cobbled
cobbled together that would have been on
the cutting room floor was it filmed we
never made it we never made it we
probably we made I think probably at the
end of the day we did about two hundred
and sixty sketches and there's probably
about five or six that never made it on
the air and mostly because we thought
they were B pluses and not AIDS not for
content not for content but because of
because of the quality and that was the
one sketch we just we had never had any
idea what the show was going to end up
being so we just kind of went oh no man
I don't know it's like Kennedy it's like
it's like a Kennedy like can you still
really don't do Kennedy sketches you
know it's like there's certain things in
our American history Abe Lincoln aid
like it like we still like every now and
again you might do an Abe Lincoln they
might talk about him going to the
theater in an improv sketch well you get
the joke of other than that how did you
like the performance how mrs. Lincoln
it's just like yeah other than that
exactly which and it's still like even
even like two percent of me Blanche's
even when you say
that's 100 bucks ooh poor Mary Todd do
you I don't know if you and peel drink
because when we go out to dinner yeah
it's feels like we come up with ideas
and again I even go back to some of the
greatest albums ever produced or when
guys were on drugs any Domino's right
Eric Clapton right getting Floyd Floyd
yeah Rolling Stone Exile on Main Street
but do you guys drink we don't we um you
know it's funny for Jordan for a very
long time I am at I do enjoy alcohol but
we never we would never like use it we
never use it as a tool okay no now there
may be a member of the team that has
sometimes supplemented their creative
input with perhaps marijuana but and to
enter great effect I may say I think I
think the entire east/west bowl sketch
we're going to talk about that you know
what let's take a break I want to talk
about right yes we're going to take a
break here
that's called a tease it's still to come
he's keegan-michael key
friends from colleges on Netflix also I
I did tell I told Kagan about your it
you're running with Cobie Smulders
servicing oh no you didn't yeah I did
it'll tell me oh you know it happened to
the best show so see okay oh wait we're
doing to taste guys is what it is we'll
continue with keegan-michael key after
this I'm a damn pleasure two friends
from college now on Netflix you can also
be seen playing the role of Horatio in
Hamlet off-broadway at the public
theater scene O'Connor had a run-in with
one of your co-stars from friends from
college this is at a Saturday Night Live
party yeah like that rat party after oh
yeah yeah because Kobe was married to
Taran Killam regrets SNL for several
years yes right pick up the story from
there scene O'Connor well I was I was
like beside myself because it was like
that place that you're like how why am i
here how did I get into the base player
from Radiohead is getting a drink next
to me yeah Baldwin's over there so I was
very much in that space and fanboying
taran killam heart oh yeah so good so
funny right and I'm like oh my god it is
amazing like can you believe Saturday
live you must love
whatever and his wife is standing next
to him and my wife they're having a
conversation and they are we sort of
cross over and like hey so like what do
you do remember she's like oh I'm in TV
too and oh yeah well you know he's in
New York and I'm in Los Angeles oh wow
that must be tough for the family and
right you know it's sort of like mom on
mom wife on wife just talking and my
wife's like so what do you do again
she's just like well I'm on a TV show
and she's like oh but what do you do
like are you like makeup or production
or something or don't you like knowledge
I'm not it come on it like oh did
anything I ever heard oh so then you
know my wife immediately recognized oh
it's like the biggest show on TV and
like she's like I'm sorry we just don't
watch TV a lot I don't know of course I
know the show but we can we don't ever
watch TV oh I'm so sorry
the other thing is she's so that one
everything talent Beauty kindness and
the thing is that's what she'll always
be she's very unassuming in that way
Cobie is that she would but that sums up
how we meet celebrities right there
yeah that's out right there yeah it's
always awkward it's not always yet when
did you know you were famous I think the
very first I was walking with down the
street I was walking on like the corner
was like the corner of Vermont and
Prospect in Los Angeles and a car full
of kids was driving the opposite way and
they lit and they made the effort to
lean out of the window and go cochons
cochons from imagine TV and that was the
first time that had happened there'd
been smattering of recognition
smatterings of recognitions before that
but that was the first time I went oh
there's something happening here then
then I can't pinpoint another moment
that's really kind of one of the moments
where I went also we're just leaned out
of a car but then after that it's not
until we started do it like Jordan I did
a number of live shows at colleges and
you started to realize oh oh there's
something when they start reciting yeah
that's and that's a big one Danis when
they start reciting the lines or or or
they start or you look on your Twitter
and go what oh these people are really
they're really really paying attention
because it's such an isolated thing the
difference between being on television
and being on stage it's an important
thing then you work with President Obama
oh yeah yeah that's that's a completely
different level yeah that was a
completely wait but his sense of humor
of you your sense of humor like what
that compatible very much so except for
that he's very wry and dry with his
sense of humor there's a there's a I
wouldn't necessarily describe him as
droll I would very clever and wry though
because sometimes he'll say something
and you'll go oh like it just it's like
it's like a Blackbird stealth bomber
just kind of flying under the radar
but when did you feel like you had to
let you know when I'm here around a
funny guy you feels like you have to
laugh a little more a little bit I will
say I was at a presidential when he's
not now that he's not president would
you be laughing and everything you left
it I probably would not be laughing at
everything he said but I would I would I
didn't but I would still give him come
in a couple days I go ooh well played oh
well played but I'm looking at all these
so you you impersonated all these
characters here Ludacris Snoop Bill
Cosby Al Roker Terrell Owens Tyler Perry
Keith Richards all of these guys I'm
gonna say 50% to 60% of those
impressions was was the amazing work of
our makeup team okay because I never
uttered a word as Keith Richards three
and a half hours of makeup I wish we had
a picture I wish I could show you fifty
three half hours of makeup and I mean
everything Molly you'll find everything
ears eyebrows they put jowls on me that
the makeup was unbelievable and I never
had to utter a word so it's the best
impression I've ever done and never had
another award but but especially a man
TV which was a highly decorated team at
the make up there was amazing and we
stole one of the makeup artists from a
show to do Key & Peele and it was it was
amazing so you know both of those
impressions were with a makeup team yeah
also talking about the the east-west
bull game where the player introductions
yeah yeah yeah where the idea come okay
so we were sitting in the office one day
and Jordan says to me he goes he played
he would play um and you played mad man
all the time and he was not a huge
football fan he wasn't a football fan
but just happen to like Madden and he
said he said he can did you know that
there is an offensive lineman who plays
for the New York Jets and his name is to
break aschoff or is it and I went oh
yeah and he said my man's name is Nick a
Shaw and I went oh oh my darling Jordan
that's the tip of the iceberg
it's a British I may as well be John
Smith compared to some of the people out
there playing football so he was like
really and I said oh yeah check check
like you know there are players who have
very colorful names so one day two weeks
later a week later I stroll into the
office and Danny just like this is he
hands me a script each minute and I
guess like what's this and I'm just
going through and there's this cavalcade
of names I'm just going okay so let's
just make this did you win did your
white men go sire no it's kind of toying
around with it last night last night and
he said I might've had some thoughts and
I bet he wrote the whole thing and I
think maybe I can't remember
maybe I contributed Dan Smith the guy
who went to be light at the end but but
other night he wrote every single one of
those name any odd ha ha Clinton bit ha
ha cleanse dick s ha ha frosty rocker is
mainly kitchen and D'Brickashaw the
triggers are did that for us and then
somebody else is mainly kitchen is a
fantastic name that is a fantastic named
silverberry Mouton self-repairing notes
on I just I applauded I miss just not
even sarcasm I applaud the the
imagination of these women because I
want their babies they want the babies
to be individuals in the world now there
are some people I think who have names
where it's it's kind of hard to live up
to a name but I mean if it's something
if you're going to name your child
peerless peerless plush that's the name
that's like something that's like you
came out of the womb with about with a
goal God sham God sham God was the one I
was trying to think of I could God sham
God yeah I Hey
you named the anger you've got you've
got something to aspire to but then you
came up with mccringleberry but yeah
Jordan came up with Jordan made sure to
put in schools that were important to me
so he put in Wayne State he put in he
put in Adams say he put in French state
and when I was the when I went to go do
our homecoming a couple years ago I had
a mccringleberry Jersey and it was
insane it was absolutely insane it's
really love the love that I get from my
alma mater is really well it was Antonio
Brown
imitating mccringleberry when he got
flags did three pump the funny thing
about his three pump as she's doing that
he was doing a back three pump right so
he's doing okay okay here we go
oh there we go Kringle berries doing
that was a reverse I was like okay
Antonio now you get you get point us for
creativity than for doing the us remove
and double reversed it but but you know
didn't you know who did it it was Kenny
Britt and and Lance Moore they for real
for real did it where he was Lance Moore
was the first one to really do it scored
a touchdown Kenny Britt runs next to him
takes his diaper right and he stands
there he did the full of the form was
perfect and and Kitty Brett even threw
the flag like even threw the flag which
was a lock you should go hey they're
fine okay Jordan I paid on Miller's fine
because he had perfect for month three
Papa how much was that
fifteen grand so we just both gave like
I don't know seven grand to the he's a
foundation in Denver for the kids they
get the glasses for the kid oh yeah he's
a good guy
good job on Miller great form I love
that I love this skit because he'll is
looking he's waiting he's down on his
knees he's waiting I'm gonna if you if
you pump them if you pump one what the
flag to uh it was he's so Jordan is so
amazing because he he the the way the
way of always kind of describe Jordan
creatively is like a Vienna if you had a
vase of roses a dozen roses everybody is
in hundred people in the room
ninety-nine people would say would say
look at that gorgeous bouquet of roses
Jordan would say wonder if that vase was
made in Taiwan you know it's like that's
the difference between Jordan Peele
everybody he's very considered the way
he thinks
and his observations are he's just he's
quite quite brilliant drama or comedy
tougher comedy much tougher because what
you're trying to do in comedy is whilst
you're in character there's a little
Shakespearean I got it
well no I got it whilst you're in
character the course McCarrick tur
doesn't think anything is funny the
actor knows it's funny so like you're
like 75% in character immersed 25% you
has to be has to remain perfectly
technical because the actor has
get the timing right the character has
to be living truthfully in the given
circumstances of the moment but then you
have to ride the line so that you get
the timing right
whereas in drama you can just slop it
out there you can just open yourself up
and just let it go and that performance
is what it is that night
comedy it's like running but please run
the same route every time please please
prevent Marvin Jones please run the
route the same way every time so so that
it makes it harder because you're trying
to be as organic and realistic as you
can and at exactly the same time
maintain the rhythm of the performance
where you don't always have to have the
rhythm correct in drama every audience
coming to see a drama is going to see a
different little wrinkle in the show
every night that's going to be a little
different yeah were you offered a pardon
get out I was not I was not I there the
casting I think and get out was done
absolutely perfectly I didn't want to
have I wanted it was Jordan had such a
perfect idea of what he wanted that
piece to be and he would discuss with me
every now and again I'm thinking about
this guy thinking about that guy oh he's
good and then I back up it's it's just a
lovely thing because it has nothing but
his fingerprints all over it it's his
you're watching his comic DNA on-screen
and his and he's also his love for
horror on screen in a way that you've
never seen it before it's just a
masterpiece the show is friends from
college now on Netflix this is all yours
this is your baby but though this is
Nick Stoller okay so you know this I'm
solely an actor just a hired gun on this
thing oh yeah I did I did not I did not
create this Nick Nick Stoller and his
wife Francesca Delbanco the next dollar
really you know terrific terrific comedy
director in it most and most limited
neighbors and and and writes a lot of
stuff and he's really quite fantastic
and he was like would you want to come
and do this I'm like I would love to
work we just made the animated film
storks with him me and Jordan and it was
such a blast and we have very similar
comedic sensibilities so I really wanted
to do it you want to be a bad guy yes
very well you know it for people who've
seen the show you're not a great guy
start out with
he's got he's got some flaw when you're
sleeping with somebody and every time by
enemies pregnant right a man other than
that and that's how you start the show
so it's it's that there's a lot of
there's a lot of issues there that I
think we're fun to play not a bad guy
also an actor should never see the
character they're playing as a bad guy
there's no way Anthony Hopkins ever for
one second thought Hannibal Lecter was
evil
thought Hannibal Lecter was fun and had
taste and was smart and that's how you
have to see the character so but to play
like a purely evil guy I would love to
do that one day either either on stage I
haven't done that since like school I'd
love to play a purely despicable person
and see what how that challenge would
would roll out best comedy of all time
is one movie uh for my money the best
comedy of all time is actually Midnight
Run Midnight Run Charles Grodin and
Charles Burton Robert De Niro Dennis
Farina Billy yeah Peter Marino is very
underrated as a comedian it's I would
say this too it is that I believe is
also a capsule and time of De Niro's
best ever comedic work ever he's great
in King of Comedy made parents to me I'm
sorry actually you're right Meet the
Parents - because it's a that's a full
comedy a second a very close second a
fraternal twin for me is Young
Frankenstein and you can't realize a
tonic I mean it really a real brain
Stein I just think found four-pound
because the tone is right but for me
that Marty breast film Marty breasts by
the way a director who I adore because
he took movies he did what we were
trying to do with Keanu which was make a
movie that had lots of laughs where the
bullets are real and he did it with with
you know it with uh Beverly Hills Cop
and 48 hours and a midnight run to me is
an absolute masterpiece because they're
playing real characters everything's
real none of the comedies ever pushed
and it's just ah yeah the show friends
from college you can see keegan-michael
key play a not so good guy I'm not so
good yet it's on Netflix and also of
course he plays the role of Horatio and
Hamlet off-broadway at public theater
theater theater yeah I couldn't do it
give
in English accent to break here so say
goodbye in your English your
mid-atlantic accident thank you so much
for joining us today on the dawn hold on
pawns never get a certificate thank you
so much for joining us today here on the
Dan Patrick show I have been
keegan-michael key
Espeon producer impresario I thank you
Dan for your time as I take us to break
thank you so much everyone and have a
wonderful wonderful day the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience